as que já vão começar por fazer uma
pergunta toda a gente
um repto que é a razão é que eu estou
aqui a falar e vocês estão aí a ouvir o
que você está fazendo errado na nossa
vida escolhas erradas e que a nova
fazenda também estava só em imitar aqui
o sesi manteve se nos píers eu tenho um
bocadinho e não adoro falar em público
gastou falar mais devagar a perceber que
estou mais calma e não sabemos bem que
vim aqui dizer mas não vai aceitar eu
estou aqui me o favor vamos nunca
ninguém perceber que o carro estava a
fazer dentro do próprio e seu mas numa
estrangeiras mas filmamos vaiaram o
atentado foi filmado dentro de um carro
também porque era tudo bem feito e
depois fui fazendo sempre o que é que
estava só e ii ea um dia aparece uma
coisa nova que são estas redes sociais
por que fazer isso como a melhor amiga e
para os meus amigos apareceram as redes
sociais e sobretudo facebook onde até
não sou eu mas eu tenho as minhas
páginas no facebook e que as redes
sociais têm uma vantagem muito grande
porque eu acho que inverteram o processo
também que as criativas nos ares não sei
nem me interessa é da área criativa
inverteu muito o processo de inscrição
das doze trabalhos das comissões podem
mostrar ao mundo porque é como se fosse
uma grande sala das sessões onde está
toda a gente a avaliar o trabalho
criativo é quem faz coisas quem saem
antes quem escreve e canta jazz índia
por exemplo foi descoberto no youtube
mas também houve coisas positivas com
certeza garante no centro
mas aqui a e no meu caso é um crime ao
contrário como costuma ser que eu
comecei as tiras de favelas fez as
primeiras coisas que eu fiz mas tem mais
páginas e finge para uma amiga em
particular a 14 de novembro
e minha idéia é continuar só fazer
aquilo e depois tem esta partida que as
redes sociais têm quieta as coisas
tomarem as virais e foi o que aconteceu
e aí a coisa não querem mais a sério é a
página que chega e tem um fato bastante
fácil light como lhes chama de fazer
outras coisas também como pajé é para
gente que apagou a presidenta em
saudação à nossa madrinha coletiva a
américa latina da emissora mesmo por
acaso na vida real e não consegue fazer
outras coisas e ter um canal no youtube
também cervejas mendes fighter pode
fazer é se a nós pra mim e agora o que
fazer o resto temos a falar em mim sou
eu e depois agora consegue fazer coisas
um crime sério escrevo e tenho minhas
filhas não usual e agora vou refletir um
bocadinho sobre a responsabilidade pode
ser aqui é ter um público começava a ter
um público é chato fazer coisas chocam
com os amigos e dentro de um carro
o governo americano nada traz de viseu
que é essa responsabilidade está em
pessoas houve ouviremos e das mensagens
que nós queremos passar é uma relação
que eu fui fazendo e fui percebendo ver
certa maneira que é chegar às pessoas e
ligar isso como fazer um namoro eu acho
graça tudo - é e você vê que o humor é
uma arma e isso é uma atitude
o amor é uma arma importante cima
provavelmente da arma mais importante e
neste mundo nós vivemos as coisas nem
sempre são bonitas e
é um jogo era uma visão que temos do
futuro também não é uma coisa própria
mente brilhante seja por causa embora só
temos estes dois a dois anos porque um
falou sobre o problemas ambientais ou
seja a própria terra não tem o futuro
provavelmente brilhante e depois as
pessoas que habitam também não tem uma
previsão muito muito bonita de se ver o
futuro e como eu faz do mundo o humor é
aquilo que eventualmente acabará por
salvar o estudo
nós não vamos ficar a rir quando tivemos
um cometa contra a terra de semana eu
vou ter certeza se isso aconteceu e
pronto e fala se muito nos limites do
humor e nenê no mar com marman que 80
sobre isso
muito nervosa porque quem é e advogar
mais aquilo que tinha de dizer acho que
saltando em outra coisa que também está
ouvindo a conversa sol o almoço que
tivemos e acho que mais do que o humor
também tem que nos ligaram porque tinha
paixão pelas coisas que nós fazemos aqui
hoje vão para pessoas muito diferentes e
falar de coisas muito diferentes mas
acho tão bonito tá vamos todos
apaixonados pelos os nossos sistemas e
pelas nossas coisas e com essas duas
características ou a paixão que pomos
nas coisas que fazemos e naquelas que
acreditamos e depois com humor e com a
rir se calhar podemos tornar estas
coisas todas é um bocadinho nós
fronteira para acabar numa nota mais
positiva e numa coisa mais bonita que
dado e é isso que eu vim aqui dizer acho
[Aplausos]
[Música]